اذا بينما تستمر هذه التحقيقات حول الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق دونالد ترامب يسير هو على
مسارين قانوني واخر نفسي ونفسي لديه يعني
اثاره الغضب والغضب ثم الغضب في نفوس
انصاره يوم امس وعند انتقاله من نيوجيرسي
الى فلوريدا تعهد ترامب بالانتقام السياسي
من لائحه الاتهام التاريخيه الموجهه له
بتهمه اساءه التعامل مع وثائق سريه وفي
منشور له على موقعه تروس سوشل توعد ترامب
بتعيين ما اسماه مدعيا خاصا حقيقيا لتحقيق
وملاحقه جو بايدن وعائلته ما يوضح
استراتيجيه ترامب السياسيه في مواجهه
التهم التي سيحاكم عليها فيما يامي اليوم
طبعا يوم السبت وخلال تجمع جماهير قالت
ترامب ان الشعب الامريكي غاضب وان المعركه
النهائيه جاريه لانفاذ البلاد على حد قوله
كما ردد بعض العبارات التي استخدمها قبل
الهجوم على الكابيتال في يناير 2021 طبعا
تعليقات ترامب واذا ما اضفنا اليها تجربه
الكابيتال اطلقت اشارات التحذير فيما يامي
التي اعلن قائد شرطتها مانوال موريس ان
السلطات المحليه وضعت بالحسبان احتماليه
ان تاخذ الامور منعطفا نحو الاسوا طبعا
صحيفه
استطلعت اراء محللين منهم جمهوريون اشار
البعض لان ترامب وبعيدا عن الجانب
القانوني سيعمل على كسب الجمهور من خلال
تصوير نفسه على انه مضطهد وانه خاطر
باثاره التوتر السياسي او حتى العنف بينما
قال احد الناشطين الجمهوريين المقربين من
ترامب ان الاخير سيحاول كل ما في وسعه
لابطاء المحاكمه مما يمنحه فرصه اكبر
لايصال رسائله السياسيه قبل اصدار اي حكم
مساعدونا سابقون للترامب اكدوا ان مواقفه
مبرره وانها ستس سياسيا خاصه مع تصدره
لاستطلاعات الراي في الحزب الجمهوري الا
انهم ابدوا تخوفهم من ان تلقي لائحه
الاتهام الفيدراليه تلقي بظلالها عليه في
الانتخابات العامه بينما قال اكاديميون
لفاينال تايمز ان وجود رئيس سابق في
مواجهه ضد القضاء هو امر خطير قد تكون له
عواقب بعيده المدى ربما تجعل الثقه في
المسار القانوني هشه للغايه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات